good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday it has been a
minute since we've seen you guys welcome
hello jacqueline how are you i'm great
how are you you're the one who was off
globetrotting this weekend it was an
international tour yeah you were all
around the world yes i had the first
official three shows of oh my almost
said the djt no end log and live and i'm
wearing my not like other girls
sweatshirt because
spoiler alert she's not like other girls
thank you jackie took the words right
out of my mouth all available at
shopmorningchost.com we've got koozies
beanies sweatshirts we're selling merch
at shows limited merch only two or three
styles we've got about six or seven on
shopmorningtoast.com so you know what i
want to show everyone my favorite
precipitation hold on am i you're
getting up for it too
you guys i didn't even ask her to do
this
because that's how cute it is okay i
agree i designed this one
with a very specific like inspo in mind
it's a t-shirt these are what ones are
being sold at the show but there's more
sizes i were going to the unlocked tour
and i wanted to buy merch to wear to the
show it would be this t-shirt like with
thigh high boots oh that's cute
so it's giving selena it's giving early
2000's like jonas brothers i wanted to
do like a vintage concert t-shirt and
that's exactly what i did the dates are
on the back i didn't know you performed
at the queen elizabeth theater this
weekend yes i did prestigious no it's my
second time there and it's a fabulous
theater really really gorgeous i didn't
know that they were honoring queen
elizabeth in such a way yes i was in the
commonwealth this weekend right canada
queen right yeah yeah so i was at the
queen elizabeth theatre yeah it was
great i mean
minneapolis detroit toronto do you know
how relieved i am to just have this
first leg behind me just i have these
shows under my belt and now i have like
this confidence because i've been
dreaming of sitting here today like i've
been envious of the girl who's sitting
here and she's not like other girls and
she's not like other girls and she has
this experience behind her and it was
better than i could have imagined well
yeah just to to your horn because i
think it's it comes it's different when
it's someone else but like the fanfare i
was seeing online the chatter online
everyone had the greatest time i heard
from like friends friends of friends and
then also the toasters that like people
were just immensely enjoying themselves
like laughing at the jokes like as they
fell asleep at night like which is oh
that's so funny that's so nice which is
like when you know something that's
exactly what you ate funny and so i
think it was a smash success yeah i feel
really good you know it was it's a lot
of work like going out and especially
like i fly in the morning of a show and
then i fly out the next morning so i get
no sleep i had to go through the border
it was like really kind of torture
travel and you know me at such a low
threshold for anything even remotely
like inconvenient but i found myself
like not being bothered so much by the
torture which is so unlikely i think
it's because you haven't been you
haven't had the privilege of traveling
and being tortured in so long no that's
not it i really thought about it on the
way home as i like cried on the airplane
i'm like why
was this weekend different from all the
other weekends and i think i've had so
much anxiety about this tour and like a
lot of self-doubt like what i
accomplished on the djt for me was like
a far-off fantasy and it will never
happen again and i really thought that
like it was imposter syndrome like i
really thought i wasn't going to be able
to you're one hit wonder i really did
like i told all my good stories at the
djt and i've nothing else has happened
to me and when i was
doing the shows i really i felt very
strong and confident in myself in my
material and i really felt like for the
first time it's gonna be so lame but
like i just really felt like i was
exactly where i was supposed to be like
doing what i was supposed to do being
who was i was supposed to be and like
killing it on all fronts and it just
felt like how can one be miserable when
you're in that headspace claudia you
know that's beautiful thank you to quote
the djt i look forward to seeing the end
log tour
so that i have new material to quote to
quote you with yeah no i i mean i keep
sending you videos but i really want you
to experience it the first time it
sounds like what you gave
minneapolis detroit and toronto
was everything and different from the
prep shows yes the show constantly
involves i'm really a great improver but
you can't go on stage in front of it
it's not a plan it's not a plan you
can't just go up and like i'm gonna
improv i wish i could because i think my
improv is sometimes better than my
written jokes and some of the best
moments in shows are just totally off
the cuff but you can't plan for that you
know so you've got to have like good
bones of a show but yeah it's easy to
ad-lib in toronto you know like because
the people are just weird and different
like you're you're literally in a
different country which i always [ __ ]
forget like you know they don't know the
song education connection
really in toronto even though it played
on the end
they didn't like it's different channels
it's a different country i just
associate with degrassi i would assume
that they know better than all of us
yeah but they didn't watch degrassi on
the end they watched on like their
channel right so it was just like
different cultural things but it was
great i'm very grateful to everyone who
came out i'm very excited for the next
six months and i'm also very excited to
have like a little bit of a break
well we're excited for you we are glad
that you're back we have a strong two
weeks ahead of us and then you guys it
it tis the season our last show of the
year will be december 17th and so i i
always feel like these two weeks of the
year are some of our like best like this
was like dachshund week this was robert
flatts like this rascal this is always a
great time of year yeah and and so i'm
just really excited to
get like for the rest what the rest of
the year holds yeah i think like we're
everyone has that mentality towards the
end of the year where they're just like
[ __ ] it like nothing that happens really
this week like matters and so we're just
throwing caution to the wind yeah so we
have so much to discuss today wait but
you also had an exciting weekend i think
you should share i did i had a very busy
weekend for a not busy girly um
so on saturday i actually shot a little
something fun that you may or may not
see depending on how you feel depending
on how it comes out
but uh no i took a little maternity pics
and i think they're gonna i think they
were like i think they're gonna turn out
beautiful yeah i went somewhere that was
like totally you know they it's
maternity habits to nuts like they have
it all covered and they made me feel so
comfortable and like they have all of
the different looks and everything so i
really didn't have to you know muster
anything up on my own so we'll see it'll
be a few weeks before i like get the
pictures back but
did you do any nudies
you'll have to wait and see
i'm so excited
i hope you like them because i really
want you to be able to share them yeah
so tbd but that was like a fun
experience and you know everybody told
me that i should do it and i think a lot
of you know especially when you're
pregnant for the first time a lot of
women do it so um i would recommend it
it was a pleasant experience except like
it's very laborious on your body when
you're you know already breaking down
so when i got home i was broken
bro kid it was crazy
and then yesterday i had my closet
organizers come over twice as organized
um zoe and michaela they're two sisters
and they did such an amazing job and
it's so jealous it's given me a new joie
de vivre for the apartment and like i
wore a different shirt today than i've
been wearing for last month because i
saw it no shirt i feel that 100
see a shirt wear a shirt no that's the
philosophy but the hard part is the
seeing right but they take care of that
so thank you girly girls it was really
enjoyable so it was a very productive
weekend i read a lot this weekend i
finished the book i was reading which
was the hearts of militable furies by
john boyne which was so good like it was
a masterpiece it was extremely in-depth
and involved and the long af but worth
every second and just a wonderful prose
you know what i have to thank you for
something oh i do who for me
okay so this was my first time like
being on like a long leg of tour that i
haven't had a kindle like was really
into reading i don't think i read one
morsel of anything you should just like
scroll my phone on the long flights and
the long like hours in the dressing room
but i read two books this weekend and
the time like i got to my detroit
dressing room like six hours early and i
just it zoomed by it was really such a
joy thank you for giving me your kindle
not even making me pay for it like you
just handed it over and thank you for
opening my eyes to the world of
literature because i read two amazing
books i read the something blue
something borrowed series because i had
watched something barred i'm like this
movie is so good and then everyone's
like the book is better so i was like do
i need to really read the first book in
the series if i've seen the movie six
thousand times and you know what i did
but you do not have to but the book was
really good but it's
verbatum the movie it's actually crazy
that's great like conversations like to
a t
and then i read something blue the
sequel and i finished it yesterday and
it was the cutest book i've ever read in
my life and i don't know why they never
made the sequel that's frustrating
because everyone's like something blue
is better and you know what
book wise it was better oh my god i'm
feeling tempted it was so
cute and you know what i liked that i'd
seen the movie before because uh darcy
was in it rachel wasn't really in it
ethan was in it and i was like john
krasinski like yeah marcus was in it so
i like knew the characters what they
looked like and it was fun to visualize
yeah so i really it's like so late but
they have to make a movie
i think they might have missed the boat
me too but that's frustrating i wonder
why they didn't maybe the first one
didn't no the first one is a cult
classic but like maybe it didn't perform
i think it i think it really performed
well it's like so many it's one of my
like top 10 favorite movies it is really
good and even though i despise jennifer
goodwin she couldn't even ruin it is it
jennifer goodwin or is it finnifer
foodwin
no it's jennifer no i don't know that it
is it's not i think it's someone who
looks a lot like her no jackie i'm
telling you it's 100 jennifer goodwin
hold on let me just something
i'm telling you i know it is cast i just
need to make sure
oh yeah it's just a good one yeah
so even she could have ruined the movie
for me and it was just so good and i
love that movie and it was such a joy to
read the books it really was oh and i'm
trying to read okay so you made me
really cognizant of my reading challenge
which like i wish i didn't
so i'm trying to get to 30. i'm at 25. i
think i can do it you will do it plus
with vacation time like all we do is
read yeah that'll be good and then i
also started yesterday the rose code
which is the historical fiction i got a
goodreads email update about you
um and everybody has been telling me to
read it and it's also like nominated for
like historical fiction of the year it's
like the book and it's it is really good
and there's like a little prince philip
in there but i don't know how like if it
is based in reality whatsoever like did
he ever date osla i don't know i don't
want to google it because i don't want a
spoiler yeah um but just like philip
r.i.p oh right right right too soon yeah
it was like the girl that he was dating
before he like the ballerina before he
went no before he got wiped out god i
got i got it ballerina was during the
girl he was dating during world war ii
got it
wow that's so crazy that prince philip
was alive and he was alive during world
war ii yeah that is so crazy um so we
have a great show we've got the fast
five and there was a lot to discuss we
also have a tv recap real housewives of
salt lake city was on last night i
watched a little bit of coming out
colton and i gotta talk about it you do
and now at which point should i share my
annie live thoughts oh my god okay i
don't know what do you think i feel like
right now because it sounds like i'm
gonna give a recap i just need to give
major commendations to everyone in the
cast and the crew because it was as good
as it could possibly have been for like
a live show nbc live in like considering
some of what we've seen which has been
tragedy like i do have some notes but
over but even with my notes i would say
it was a 10 out of 10. like it was
fantastic i thought everybody like
carried their weight everybody did a
really good job no one was cringe i mean
major shout out to the campers the
orphans
gave us everything they left it all on
the sound stage it was incredible to
watch them like they they did not stop i
was so those were the best scenes like
hard knock life never fully dressed
without a smile like the campers were
knocking it out of the park so i
obviously had a show the night of
that minneapolis thank you everyone who
didn't stay at home to watch eddie live
and came to see and then i was like you
know what i'll watch it on the plane or
whatever and then i was like you know
what any live is like a
a cinematic event i don't want to just
rush it on an ipad like i need to be at
home i need to have my vibes cultivated
i should make a chili yeah so i decided
to wait he loves chili i decided to wait
okay well
one thing you're not going to like about
it was that it was far too long
it was three hours but i'll watch it
without commercials it'll be like 2 30.
there were so many songs and scenes that
they were clearly just doing like to
drag it out sell more commercials
wendy's was doing spots like in the
retro 1932 which was cool it was like
annie's in 1932. yeah
a classic yeah no it's like depression
era
and you know fdr
and annie inspired the new deal good to
know
um
it's like staff is so cute i love her
she did she's so cute
um so it was far too long they
incorporated like songs from the
different movies because like they did
nyc which is from the first movie
but like they didn't do let's go to the
movies which is from the second movie
because they don't both move so they
picked and choose from each movie let's
go to the movies is a good one i know
but you know what nyc is really iconic
and like i don't know if anybody else
feels this way but the woman who sang
three bucks two bags won me she had like
one verse
star who do you think performed the best
like harry
this is gonna be so i thought everybody
did an amazing job and maybe because of
like my expectations for certain people
i felt most blown away by nicole
scherzinger i heard that she was grace
like i heard that to a t
she's
such a performer they all were such
performers so i don't i'm not taking
away from anyone else but like the
singing the dancing they gave her one of
um in one of the movies grace has her
own song that zach like can't stop
singing around the house really
it's not even like a real song it's just
like her like dancing around saying we
got annie that's
funny yeah
um which it's not a big enough song for
her but they clearly wanted her to have
a moment because like she's an
incredible dancer and singer and i'm
glad that she had a moment but it wasn't
even big enough for her but she was just
so elegant and like you didn't feel like
you're watching nicole scherzing right
you're just watching grace so i and i
felt that way about everyone really like
no even harry connick jr i know
everyone's like coming for his bald cap
but like we need to move on they're
literally coming for his head they're
coming for his head we need to move on
from the ball cap but
when i was watching i didn't feel like
oh here's harry connick jr you know
devoting his time to a little community
i just felt like he was part of the show
so
i really like that i thought titus was
amazing like titus is a star titus was
just
a perfect like he was perfect taraji p
henson was really good i feel felt like
on the acting stuff she had hannah
getting down to a t but she's not really
a singer so when she was singing i was
like well she hit this no that no and
she did okay and everything went well
and megan hilty who stepped in for james
house i would have loved to see jake but
megan hilty is clearly a broadway vet
and she is i think she came in two days
before i learned every line learned
every step yeah i have no concerns about
her a plus okay so everyone did their
jobs and did them well and now i have to
talk about annie um she was so cute and
she i don't i didn't see any mess-ups
like she really
nailed it nailed it she really really
did her voice the in the beginning i was
like when they started with maybe which
is a tough song yeah and i was like oh i
i don't know if any live is going to be
for me but then it like hard knock of
life it just like really turned around i
thought she was so good she was so
professional and
um
she had some scenes with sandy and i was
like getting nervous because i was like
what if sandy's like [ __ ] off no that's
true they had a real dog they had a real
dog but then there was only one scene
with sandy in the movie and i do feel
like it was pre-recorded because they
did say good portions are pre-recorded
because we didn't need to see san diego
and let's not torture the dogs like no i
mean we didn't need to see sandy going
rogue and running away that would [ __ ]
up the whole story
but like then sandy was like m.i.a the
rest of the show and brew was upset
because he was promised sandy that's
true but then when they were doing all
the cast bows and stuff she like really
like brought sandy over it was so cute
that is so cute her parents must be so
proud of her like oh my god he
it was an amazing feat and everything
there was a few sound issues there was a
few like shots where the camera was just
like showing back but like overall
that's live that side i would say that
my only other critique was like there
were some musical numbers
that were just like the backup dancers
like when it was um
what i think i'm going to like it here
or even nyc they they go see a show and
i felt like the show that they were
seeing it could have been bigger better
more razzle dazzle like more dancing and
it was a little bit
lackluster so um i would have liked more
more dancing would be my critique but
it was better than i could have ever
than i thought it was going to look like
i think like the hype that we gave annie
live like it wasn't enough was and no we
weren't like overdoing it like no i
think for a while we were doing it
satirically but now they've really
proved themselves like i thought it was
going to be good but still like a little
cringe as well lives are there wasn't
really no cringe love that i'm so like
looking forward to watching it in a
peaceful gorgeous cultivated environment
yeah and i will give my thoughts as well
i just didn't want to like watch it just
to watch it and like torture myself yeah
no you should enjoy it you're definitely
gonna have to skip a lot because there
was a lot of um extraneous scenes fodder
but overall i'm just so happy that you
know we put our time into this thing and
and we got out what we put in because
that never happens no
never never so congratulations to and
whoever was like running the show the
whole sound stage like the the setup it
was it it worked beautifully everyone
10 of 10 good job everyone
we needed that we did as a society and
alive was necessary yeah and it's just
such a great story
a tale as old as time truly
truly um okay so i will watch that but
in the meantime now i feel ready i feel
definitely somewhat ready as ready as a
gal can be who's having dry mouth to
dive into the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode okay actually yeah i
would love some water how old is this
wednesday's water
thick
water today's episode is brought to you
by olive and june the mani system is the
answer to salon perfect nails at home
the olive and june nail polish lasts
over seven days and it doesn't chip with
the olive and june mani system each
at-home manicure comes out to just two
dollars of um per manicure and we have a
unique offer code for you guys to check
out the manny system it comes with
everything you could possibly need to do
your nails at home amazing cuticle oil
that i literally am obsessed with nail
files gorgeous polishes that are so long
lasting and they have this like really
cute silicone topper that goes on top of
their nail polish bottles which really
just steadies your hand it makes it
really easy to paint your own nails if
you're not great at it which i am not
but i found a lot of success with the
mani system
it's five steps it comes with that
patented brush handle which is called a
poppy and the most important part is the
affordability the mani system comes with
six polishes and it breaks down to two
dollars a manicure and you might be used
to spending over thirty dollars for one
manicure at a salon so
now's the time and we've got twenty
percent off your first manny system when
you use code toast so your new nail life
is here get that twenty percent off your
first manny system when you use promo
code toast at olive and june.com
again that's olive in june.com promo
code toast for 20 off
great okay our first story
came out this weekend that tristan
thompson is expecting his third child
with personal trainer marilee nichols of
houston texas according to a paternity
lawsuit
so
you guys and the baby might have been
born between then and now but it's
unclear
what's going on it's very unclear
because she also posted something on
instagram that people revealed she
posted a picture of a baby and it was a
stock photo no but it also i don't think
it was her account i think it was a fake
account oh so it's all very unclear
whether or not the baby has been born
but what we do know is that tristan got
another girl pregnant in march when he
allegedly allegedly when he was dating
chloe and that he offered her seventy
five thousand dollars in hush money
after she became pregnant while he was
dating that's terrible so yeah there's
text messages this story is like so
messy it's honestly so tristan
and it's like
i'm embarrassed we've known tristan it's
like tristan showed us who he was so
many times and i guess i just didn't
believe him you know no i feel as though
we have been majorly duped especially
like that image revamp they did for him
on
like
i believed it i believed it too and i
was really like there was a little ship
out for me chloe interest and i was like
you guys we have to give them another
chance we even like were talking about
them and we were just here for it and i
don't know why we thought like this man
could change when he cleared like
cheated on her having another child and
then also like acting in a way towards
this woman that is
right so wrong i don't know what the
worst part about this is is it the
infidelity or it's literally offering a
woman you got pregnant 75 grand to shut
up like yeah that's horrible he was also
saying how like he's going to be out of
the nba soon so he's going to be
unemployed so she's expecting child
support and like
like that she's going to live off the
land that you know she has another thing
coming so this 75 000 should look pretty
good to her yeah that that was really
embarrassing that part like his text
messages that were screenshotted and
like used as evidence he literally was
like to you know i'm retiring soon i'm
not gonna have any money so you should
take the 75 grand while you can yeah
which is just not true
well he might be retiring but he has
plenty of money
yeah so i mean it was just awful like i
don't know who i feel worse for chloe or
this other woman like
to get pregnant and then literally have
the man tell you like [ __ ] off here's
some money like that's
so
humiliating and i just really hate this
man and i'm like embarrassed that i even
ever went to bat for him i just like
when he was like chasing ufos on keeping
up i'm like oh my god this man is
harmless he's actually kind of weird
like what kind of [ __ ] could he possibly
get into no i'm so done i
have a feeling chloe is so done as well
like
how many times is this i know this is
three
it was jordan
while she was pregnant then there was
like that security footage of him like
making out with a girl at a bar jordan
wasn't while she was pregnant it was the
footage was while she like he was seen
to be cheating on her when she was
pregnant at a later date was jordan got
it and now this and that's all we know
about him right right right and so
honestly i'm sure there's more
okay he's goodbye i don't want to see
him on hulu i'm you know what
they were china they were unchina'd and
now i just want to say you unchina i did
because i believe in second third
chances i believe in 11th chances but
this is just this is too much and
he worked so hard it seemed to get back
into like everyone's good graces and
this is like why was he trying so hard
if he was still acting out it's not like
it was like okay a year passed and he
couldn't you know stop his player ways
like this happened back in march like
when we were all rooting for him like
[ __ ] you goodbye no totally i'm
officially putting you back in the china
box sorry you've been
china
see ya
our next story though kylie and travis's
w magazine cover has leaked and it
leaked in toast after dark did you see
that yes so here's what i believe
happened based on what i'm seeing is
that
subscribers of w magazine still got the
magazine this
month but it will it won't be for sale
anywhere so you can't get it unless you
had been a subscriber and it went to
your house so they stopped all the
delivery trucks you know going to like
the store
and here and there the pictures aren't
online but the pictures are in toast
after dark and then like they got picked
up on tick tock like they it started in
tid i just want to say like we are
making news yet again okay so a lot
about the magazine article and i mean i
completely understand why they're trying
to you know shut this down but i have a
few questions first of all we need to
talk about the pictures yeah
oh you're making a face yeah they were
like meh
oh my god i think if
circumstances had been different these
would be like the most iconic photos
what they were giving me like brad and
angelina and w magazine
no they were giving me like
this is the set it's
it was giving me not much honestly oh it
was giving she was giving me everything
i mean she walks out of the house and
farts and it's everything but i'm like
for a w magazine photo shoot a family
like it was kind of giving nothing like
i think back to like when we had that
first photo shoot of kim kanye in north
in vogue and while the cover wasn't my
favorite that those inside photos were
[ __ ] sickening like iconic
i was getting like muted colors and like
it was very
artsy tumbler
tumbler yeah like in a you know i just
think that if these had
come out
at a different time everyone would be
living for them we haven't seen like a
peek behind the lens there were so many
pictures they were so intimate you know
he's listening to the belly she's
showing the belly stormies everywhere
but then like the article was also
chucked full of very bizarre information
like they are not a couple and they
haven't been a couple in over two years
right but tmz is reporting that they are
very much a couple despite the w
magazine story yeah they said
tmz said sources with direct knowledge
tell tmz that kylie and travis are 100
together at the moment meaning they're
romantically involved and presumably
exclusive too not just that but tmz was
told that they were a full-blown couple
when this whole profile was coming
together for w magazine which is weird
then the next sentence which is also
weird this is from tmz said the article
slash accompanying shoot seems to have
been whipped up in early november
early november was when astroworld
happened astroworld happened like
november 5th so are you telling me that
kylie and travis used this w magazine
article to say they're not a couple so
that kylie wouldn't be attached to the
aspect
no no no i like i don't know who's wrong
but someone's someone's got their facts
twisted no i don't think anything
but also i don't believe that this was
whipped up in early november because
they would have that would mean even if
it was whipped up november first that
they would have had four days and then
they would have been like unwhip it they
could accident not this weird subscriber
model right like to me when i saw this i
was like oh this must have been done in
october because it's so you know far
removed from where they're at now but
then i was also thinking
uh
her i was trying to assess the belly and
see where she might be at
yeah
you know because the belly is
it's
like so i don't know wait i don't know
i'm confused
i'm confused as well because
them being uh not being a couple just
like doesn't track for me i'm like it it
was really surprising to see that
yeah
yeah i don't know like otherwise then
why are they doing this whole shoot like
i guess they're trying to like brand
themselves as some sort of modern family
like i guess but like if they're not a
couple and kylie single like and she
wants to get out there what like who
would want to be attached to their ex
yeah right
no this is so weird and i have more
questions than ever a hundred percent
i'm very confused yeah
they look nice though stormy looks cute
yeah i thought the pictures were really
nice and the whole timing is unfortunate
but now apparently it's not that
unfortunate and especially because tmz
is like literally the official
spokespeople for the kardashians why am
i even giving this life i'm always
inclined to listen to tmz especially as
it pertains to the kardashians but it's
this is just in direct conflict with an
article kylie and travis sat down and
spoke to w magazine about yeah i'm so
confused no they gave w magazine a lot
of time and a lot of energy
only for tmz to debunk it in 35 seconds
right and to say that they are together
which it's like if kylie's trying to
remove herself from the situation
then
i don't know what was that what does
this serve i don't know
so many questions
but none of them being answered no but
that's the latest with those two
are you ready for our next story
sure some
surprising news that is surprising that
i'm surprised okay
vanderpump rule stars raquel and james
and their engagement
surprising
and i'm surprised that i'm surprised
raquel and james kennedy have called off
their engagement the vanderpump real
stars made the announcement via
instagram on sunday with a joint
statement and a selfie that appears to
have been taken on the reunion stage
right they said after these five
wonderful years we had together we
decided we have two different goals and
made the decision to call off the
engagement we love each other very much
but we aren't in love anymore we want
nothing but the best for each other so
please keep any thoughts positive this
was really surprising like yes they are
toxic and they have all their problems
but the one thing they've never wavered
on is each other yeah so i was just
really really surprised by this and they
filmed the reunion two days ago and i
had seen like a few rumors like that
they broke up on the reunion or they
announced it on the reunion and i'm like
there's no way
and
so i wasn't that surprised because i'd
seen the rumors but just conceptually i
think this is very shocking very
shocking it feels like if there was ever
a time to break up it was during all the
tumult of the last five years but based
on what we're seeing like she's in a
great place he's in a great place raquel
is like more self-assured than ever and
i mean maybe that's eventually what
leads to her
seeking greener pastures is like she's
found her voice and like this isn't who
she wants to be with anymore
but i thought that they were so sweet
why does this always [ __ ] happen to
me like yeah when you get on board when
i get on board with a couple like they
let me down in such a way so the thing
is is that even though i really did like
ship them i think i think they were like
i think raquel was good for james i
don't know if james was good for raquel
well i mean
i don't know that he i mean he's done
some very questionable and said some
very questionable things but if you look
at her journey over the last five years
that we've known her like she came on
this show
so she's incredibly shy like
and she's really blossomed and i have to
believe that being in a in a
relationship with james like allowed her
sometimes you know if someone loves you
so much it makes you love yourself even
more yes but i do think a lot of her
blossoming probably had to do with james
i think it probably had to do with like
coming into your own becoming a
full-time cast member like having your
own platform becoming like really famous
becoming really good friends with all
those girls i think it was a lot of
things i don't think james like gave her
like the voice that she never had no but
like i think that if you're an
incredibly shy person but yes you get a
job on the show and you're really famous
that might give you this like false
sense of confidence but that's not
really real but i feel like when you're
not feeling totally sure of yourself but
someone like loves you so much and it's
like thinks you're everything of the
sort you start to see yourself the way
that they see you and so i just feel
like it's exciting
i'm not saying james is an amazing
partner i just think her blossoming is a
testament of a good relationship i agree
with you that concept yes like when
someone loves you so much it can really
like change you um i don't really see
like that that was the case for james
markell i just thought they were they
were definitely like a decent couple i
don't think this is like the greatest
love story of our generation and i think
like
it's sad that it's over
but i actually think raquel
can do way better
for sure no she's really she's coming to
her and i've become like a big fan of
hers me too and i think it'll be nice
for her to be with someone who's not
like always like center of attention
dramatic no wonder she never had a voice
she was married to like a diva who had
to be like the center of everything and
now she's like no what about me and like
maybe she'll have a man who like
worships her instead of someone she's
like always running behind trying to
catch up with perhaps but i don't think
that sushi wants to be like
or even equals they were not equals
no but there is always like you know
this star in the relationship and then
the person who's like supportive in
those worlds also do happen to change
over time but i'm not sure that she's
looking to be you know she still is that
like introverted girl she's more
confident but like i think she's very to
herself i think she is too but i think
being james's fiance is not an easy job
because we see the best of it but i
think the job just got easier is what
i'm saying you know what i mean like i
think it's been a hard job for the last
five years but like based on what we're
seeing this season i think the job is
getting easier and easier so obviously
not because they broke up well
we can speculate all we want hopefully
at the reunion we'll find out we didn't
get any concrete answers they were just
like we don't look like maybe someone
just [ __ ] cheated on someone right
right you know what they said was like
we don't love each other anymore
right so
we shall see yeah i'm just saying i was
surprised you know what like pump rules
has been so atrocious but there's been
actually a lot going on off screen
that's making i think a lot of like hype
for the reunion the la la stuff and now
this well as we say the worse the season
is the better the reunion is yeah and i
do love some good off-air drama to stir
the pot at a reunion yeah so that should
be good but i mean always sad always
said when a ship breaks down and we have
to
reassemble the parts for someone else we
need to get on lifeboats yeah we gotta
take the dinghies back to shore
but um i don't know i actually think
this could be the start of an exciting
new adventure for rock hill and i'm
looking forward to it
i'm sorry
um before we move on today's episode is
brought to you by curology curology
customizes a prescription formula with
three active ingredients picked for you
to help tackle your skincare needs
whether that's trying to take control of
acne fine lines dark spots occasional
breakouts or clogged pores you start by
answering questions online about your
skin and if it's a good fit curology
will match you with a licensed
dermatology provider who will get to
know your skin and subject to
consultation you'll get a customized
prescription cream to be shipped
straight to your door to address whether
it's your acne fine lines dark spots and
more i'm on like my second round of
curology and i also brought it with me
on tour the sizes they give you have a
lot of um product in them but they're
really travel friendly and i just think
it's the most brilliant system like i
don't know why at some point like me and
you would be using the same skincare
like we have different skin so curology
the
consultation online is very in-depth you
send pictures of your skin there's a lot
of questions about i did clogged pores
and i also have dry skin especially
seasonally so those are the things i
wanted to tackle but if you want to
tackle like fine lines or you want to
tackle acne they will
create a
product
distinctly made for your skin which is
great because your skin is different
than everyone else's and you really
shouldn't be having the same skin care
as like your other friends you can start
your curology journey just like we did
with a 30-day free trial at curology.com
toast if prescribed just pay five
dollars for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com toast to unlock
your free 30-day trial cancel anytime go
get that glow at curology.com
toast for that free 30-day trial great
okay our next story real houses of new
york star ebony williams storms the
stage at a comedy show ebony store on
the stage at a comedy show two weeks ago
in new york city after taking issue with
comments made by comic sam bloomstone in
video footage shared on social media the
real housewives of new york city star is
seen confronting him at broadway comedy
club after he referred to her as
jcpenney collection
williams clad in a black sweater black
pants and leather boots hopped up from
her seat to grab bloomstone's mic at
which point he asserted i put my life
savings at whatever you are going to say
is nothing funny completely unbothered
by the remark the bravo liberty told the
crowd it's not about being funny [ __ ]
what it's about is you respecting a
[ __ ] black queen the audience
then erupted in cheers prompting
williams to continue what we don't do is
jcpenney [ __ ] okay a [ __ ] like me you
gotta respect me bro on your worst day
okay so i think i was extremely bothered
by this story and it really wasn't until
i spoke to heather mcdonald that i got
even more angry you spoke to her so i
had texted her like okay so i had seen
this video it happened a few weeks ago
but the guy posted the video on tick
tock a few days ago and it went crazy
viral because i don't know the concept
of a heckler who then gets up on stage
is so [ __ ] insanely disrespectful and
disgusting that of course it went viral
so she had the guy the comedian on her
podcast heather mcdonald so i was like
l-o-l and i sent her a screenshot i'm
like oh man i'm about to listen to this
and she called me and i was like i was
i'm literally about to go on stage in
minneapolis i'm like i haven't had time
to finish it but like i love that you
have this guy and i don't know what you
said but i'm sure you're right like it's
um like heather was like i'm so angry
like the video if you've ever performed
anything like and you saw like you have
nothing but respect and sadness
for this man so i listened to his
podcast with heather heather was just
like irate like would like so bothered
and this guy um
was like kind of a weenie
like he i think he's new knew to stand
up and he like went out to d he was like
so mad when it happened but then he went
out to dinner with them ramona was there
bronwyn was there and then he's like
yeah and i think i'm planning to do
another show and like i'm gonna have
ebony come and do stand-up and heather
mcdonald was just like are you [ __ ]
kidding me um but just conceptually like
first of all
so he explained what happened he was
doing a set but are you sure ramona was
there yes i don't think so they went out
for dinner afterwards i listened to the
podcast he said ramona was there and
this article and barbara barbara kaye
was there i saw her in the street the
other day like
stomping down i was um in the caps like
i couldn't say hey barbara k um and
bronwyn and bronwyn's new girlfriend but
i'm not seeing romano but you say he
said bronwyn's new girlfriend wasn't
there so this article obviously did not
listen to juicy scoop
so
he said that like they were being so
[ __ ] annoying like screaming and he's
like trying to get through his nine
minutes said he was obviously excited
like nine minutes is a lot and this
table just like wouldn't shut the [ __ ]
up so to shut them up he said the
jcpenney thing like sit down shut up
yeah he finally like addressed them and
i guess that just like
gave ebony this
desire to storm the stage take the
microphone and just go on and on it's
like not being funny and talking about
how you know you have to respect a black
queen and then on the podcast the guy
was like i don't know why she said that
like i didn't even make my go-to black
queen joke that's what he said he's like
i didn't say anything about like race
and i just and then i think that he felt
super uncomfortable yeah and he went out
for dinner with them afterwards and like
he said it was all fine but like and
heather's right like heather wasn't
letting it go like because conceptually
like to heckle someone like you
seriously like should never be able to
leave your house he's the annoying
person at a comedy show who's like at
the table like being annoying and when
this person is like doing stand-up is
just a bad trait in general and usually
the the comic like we'll call you out
even say you're even like on your phone
like they will call you out that's part
of being on a comedy show to then get up
and like take the mic if this was
someone who was not famous whatsoever
right like
it would be
the loseriest thing of all it's just not
done like it and it is so disrespectful
it's so disrespectful like can i first
of all i don't want to jinx but i have
not been heckled because the toasters
are just great they like i'll be trying
to get through a joke and they're just
like wasted like theo like and you know
what and that's really positive yeah but
it's so distracting and and i know
they're not coming for me in a negative
way but i'm like do you know how much
i'm trying to remember right now like
and you throw theo and then i get sad i
think about my son that i left at home
and so it happens to me in a positive
way they're just like screaming like
taylor swift like in the middle of no
and it's so distracting so i can only
imagine how earth-shattering it is when
someone's streaming something negative
at you right um and also like we know
these women they're
animals extra like annoying ramona like
they're
they have no self-awareness they have no
they think that they're really like
a-list and you know in new york and they
are
at these type of events they are
so i loved i'm sorry i loved that
heather like blew this up because
it's abhorrent it's embarrassing it's
abhorrent behavior like if you've
imagine if you were so nervous to make
your speech at dana's
rehearsal dinner
and imagine if someone was like boo
you saw like imagine how embarrassed you
would be yeah and then i told them off
and then they came up and took the mic
yeah when you're like just clearly you
have a task to do get through your
speech it's just and if you've if anyone
listening to this podcast has ever
heckled someone at a comedy show i don't
care who it is like just know in your
soul like i literally despise you but i
think you're the worst person on the
planet it's it's the worst top 10 thing
you could do and also she gets on stage
she said it's not about being funny
you're at a comedy show it's exactly
about being funny and you know what you
weren't funny no when she got up and now
i think she's gonna like launch into
some sort of stand-up career which
really pissed heather off either so this
comedian was like i'm actually going to
put together like another variety show
and have ebony do some minutes which
just i think like heather was like okay
this interview i think this guy's trying
to be a good sport no i think this guy's
trying to like make a moment out of this
moment yeah you know when you're
comedian up and coming i don't think you
get a lot of viral moments like that
yeah and i think that you know for the
both of them like it's not it's just a
really honestly like awkward and
embarrassing
clip and i think that he's trying to
like turn it into a positive thing which
is cool yeah but as like fans of
housewives and ebony i'm this is like
it's just disappointing really bad love
you're a public figure like you're
supposed to
like act like a role model and this is
the worst thing you could do ever in a
comedy club like it just bothers me a
lot yeah i agree
now our fifth and final story little
related news adele a little one it's
related oh
adele is talking about why she doesn't
watch the housewives i know she said my
brain will die adele you are completely
correct i just can't what i'm sorry like
adele confessed that she's not a real
housewives fan and that's not going to
change any time soon she was getting her
makeup done by nikkietutorials on
youtube
yeah she said i know a lot of people
love it but i can't my brain will die i
can't she added i don't know who any of
them are so i don't feel like i can
start from the beginning when it's been
on for so long that's fair she also said
that um
like nikki said that the shows are
binge-worthy but the singer
rejected the idea saying i'm not going
to lie it doesn't work for me she said
that she gave the real house eyes of new
jersey a shot but the arguments were a
tad too intense for her liking she said
one time i did watch one episode of the
real housewives of new jersey when they
were all like literally killing each
other but it was too much i was like i
can't i can't watch she said she would
rather watch a wildlife program she
prefers
programs that are a bit more educational
and she's not interested in reality tv
in general okay like that's fine when
asked about love island she said i can't
bear that show okay i just want to say
not everyone has to watch reality tv
that's not what i'm saying but i just
think people who take like a moral high
ground on it like you're not better
because you listen to david attenborough
and i listen to luann de lesseps like i
just i hate when people like just like
look down on reality tv because you know
what a lot of it is trash but i like a
lot of it and i just hate when people
think they're like too good for it i
don't think that she's like looking down
on anything i prefer more education i
think she was asked a question and then
she's talking about the kind of tv that
she does like to watch it sounded
condescending she was asked a question
and that's the truth it makes her brain
go numb i know the feeling and i'm a
real and and i watch every single i've
seen literally every single episode and
it's mind-numbing stuff i didn't like it
i'm sure she only has a certain amount
of time on her hands but like her best
friend jennifer lawrence loves it you
know i feel like she has actually a good
amount of time on her hands
no i mean it depends i think it depends
on the year yeah of course i think she's
had a lot of time the last six years now
yes last six months maybe not so much
right so
it's not like she looks down on people
who love it jayla loves it that's her
bff and it bothered me i i actually felt
like yes can someone please say this
because like it's true but everyone says
it like that's the overwhelming
consensus in our country like reality tv
is like trash but it's like some of us
like it [ __ ] off like what if i said you
know ozark was trash you know it's true
that everyone says that but then you
look at the numbers and it's like these
housewives get more
viewers instagram
prime 100 so
like we're all watching it yeah so
and maybe because we're just so in this
world and like everyone that like we
know we're like just
in the toaster world like reality tv is
like the golden yeah so for me i'm
coming at it from a place of you know
it's not as good as we say that it is
that's true but i just feel like
overwhelming like in our country the
sentiment is like reality tv is trash or
people who watch it are dumb and it's
like [ __ ] off some of us just like it
and it's like not that serious but i
think people who say that like
unprompted out of nowhere you know like
the way that they talk about the
kardashians too when it's like nobody
[ __ ] asked and like right you go try
and make a billion dollar business for
each one of your siblings yeah go let's
see how you're doing
um that does bother me that bothers me a
lot but this just it felt like they were
just talking about like tv in general
and adele just shared her opinion like i
don't
i don't feel like you know she
was being one of those people do you
feel like you know adele's been very
selective with her press we were talking
about that guy who
didn't
do the assignment for his interview in
australia she did oprah she did these
like two concerts and then like this
random youtube video well no i've been
seeing some other stuff too she did like
uh apple music interview with john mayer
oh i saw that serious yeah yeah she's
been doing some like
zoom interviews type things and then i'm
sure she's also trying to like do some
new age stuff yeah i guess like nikki
tutorials is really like a global yeah
i'm surprised she hasn't popped onto
like armchair expert yet or like joe
rogan oh totally she should do one
podcast yes
chair expert's a good one i don't think
she would do joe rogan i mean i think
joe rogan would be so great but i feel
like she would be better suited she
probably like also
has met dak shepard yeah and like that
would just make sense you know what she
could do the morning toast she could but
she wouldn't but i think those girls are
a little booked and busy yeah
um no i would love to see her do a
podcast there's so many like that do
celebrities like conan is always yeah
and honestly it doesn't need to be the
biggest podcast because whatever podcast
adele sits down on will become the
biggest podcast
mark maron he gets some big gaps
so
she should do it give us one
give us one
morning toast
um that would be so crazy no i would
love if i could choose i would say joe
rogan if i could choose i would ask for
one with a video component so i guess i
would do joe rogan as well because i
prefer to watch than listen yeah if i
can
um those were the past five stories i
feel as though you needed to know them
definitely 100
um
and we're not done because we've got the
tv recap what should we start with salt
lake city yes and i just need to go grab
my heartburn medication oh live your
life i'll do the ad um today's episode
is brought to you by mrs fields this
holiday season we want to give each
person we care about a gift that'll
bring them joy right now there's one
place we can find that perfect gift for
everyone on your list mrs fields cookies
who doesn't love fresh from the oven
melt in your mouth cookies mrs fields
has a tasty treat package for everyone
on your list and it's a feel good giving
at its best okay i've been like head
over heels in love with mrs fields
herself for many years like i've had
gorgeous moments biting into
a cookie at a mall but this gift box we
got you guys that sat in our
studio for 30 seconds before it got
completely eaten was so delicious
and i hadn't had any of those treats
before those sugar cookies with the
frosting
such a special box of cookies that we
just we have to share it was so special
nobody does a gift like mrs fields also
some jordan almonds that oh yeah do not
break your teeth they were they melted
in your mouth it was
heaven on earth and it came in this like
gorgeous package three tiered little
christmasy it looked like a cake like
yeah with ribbons it was just gorgeous
gorgeous so obviously you should get one
for yourself because the cookies were so
good but it's a perfect gift it's a
perfect gift to bring to someone's house
for christmas if you're just like
sending someone something that you can't
see because they're a long distance like
it will make someone feel so special and
they will also eat every last bite and
it's partially decor like if you put it
under your tree or on like a mantel it
looks like a mini christmas tree it's
really cute so you can get it for
grandparents parents kids friends
co-workers there's something that will
thrill any person of any age for over 40
years mrs fields has perfected fresh
baked gourmet treats every cookie cake
confection every bite is so yummy
you can choose from a huge selection of
holiday gift baskets cookie tins i love
a cookie tin and the most fun creative
packaging anywhere like the snowman and
the polar bear towers which are designed
to delight and if you want to get 20 off
everything site-wide go to mrsfields.com
toast that's right that's mrs fields
dot com slash toast twenty percent off
everything when you visit mrsfields.com
toast mrs fie lds.com
toast
wonderful um let's do tv recap salt lake
city housewives was a very frustrating
episode because we're getting so
sidetracked with this mary nonsense i
don't know why
jen going to prison has turned into a
referendum on mary like we need to look
at everyone's finances and everyone's
businesses and everything that everyone
else has said like why can't we just
have this moment to like talk about this
one thing we need to
compartmentalize down
what's going on with jen and like where
we all stand as her friend and as
viewers in the show like what and
instead it's like no now let's bring up
everything everyone's ever said about
mary i was so and my logic makes no
sense heather was like well we knew
stuff about jen so and we didn't say
anything and now we know stuff about
mary so we have should learn from our
lesson from jim i'm not understanding
just because like there's stuff said
about that like someone and one person
went to jail doesn't mean like
everybody's engaged in criminal activity
like okay maybe maybe at worst like mary
is
unethical influencing her congregation
in a way that is a little
unsavory um but that doesn't get you
sent to prison does it no no
so here's where i landed with the
episode i
was making a lot of progress on lisa
barlow but like she did she was
two-faced like she brought up she
literally started the fire of mary cosby
she got it from that conversation
because people weren't going hard enough
on mary cosby and then she goes down and
is so [ __ ] shady like with the
presents it's weird no i have been
finding myself defending her i'll see
all season long and like just trying to
understand where she might be coming
from and when she did that i was like
goodbye i i seriously can't but then
it's like then mary doesn't care no no
but then it's like then whitney accuses
her of like masterminding this whole
thing and i don't think whitney's on the
money with her accusations either and
i'm like no i don't think lisa did all
that but like she's definitely guilty of
some [ __ ] but not what you're saying so
i really can't agree with anyone and i
now realize that lisa invited whitney to
fresh wolves obviously
like cameron to talk to her by the way
do you know that cameron is dead has
passed away yes which makes this even
like weirder spooky and just to be like
all talking about this man and he's like
the center of the drama and now he's
passed away it's like so incredibly sad
yeah and i don't even think the women
realized that a month ago lisa filmed
with cameron and got his story on the
show so she is trying she is behind this
she's pulling the strings on this whole
marry thing yes i don't know whitney
thinks it's like to come between whitney
and mary
and i don't know if it's that but we
can't expect whitney to really
understand what's going on because i
don't even understand what's going on
with lisa like how she can wake up and
be so two-faced and then they'd be so
righteous about it too like
it's it's mind-blowing but because i
find this mary's stuff to be so stupid
but i do feel like yes last night's
episode like really showed mary's true
colors and i'm sorry when she called
heather chubby like um that's i draw the
line like i officially hate mary cosby
um and then she said like a really weird
talking about like mexican thugs she was
off her [ __ ] rocker god is in her
butt
she's just delusional and i'm sorry like
whether her her church is savory or not
a quote-unquote woman of god doesn't
call another woman chubby doesn't make
like racial
things about mexicans like
i just i really i cannot stand with mary
anymore i think she's awful i agree and
but i all like i felt like half the time
i was like
uh i felt just only defensive of mary
just because it's like this isn't mary's
time these things have been said for so
long and now all of a sudden we're going
to bring them up overnight but then the
way that she defended herself i was just
like nope can't be on your side yeah i
was like lisa can't be on your side and
i was on team weather so whitney and
heather they just like get a little
dramatic
yeah and they and whitney like then goes
into like baby talking voices like lisa
you don't like me and i'm like you're
not my girl
you could have went home on the plane no
i complete i would have done the exact
same thing the only thing i would have
done differently is i wouldn't have let
them leave me on the stoop like that and
then they're going to their pj i would
like find your [ __ ] valentino back
get it get it get everywhere and go sit
at the airport and go be out of sight
out of mine but let me tell you why
things are just confusing to me here
because
we're still really not clear on what
mary did and heather's just like
writing mary off completely like not
wanting to be associated with her but
heather is also probably the only one
left in real time now who's like
standing with jen and like saying that
she needs a friend right now and she's
gonna be that friend for her and that's
what's confusing to me like you have
moral superiority like
depending on the person no i totally
agree knowing where heather stands now
made everything she said last night like
even but i don't think we can watch like
that like we need to just watch episode
by episode because as of last night i
was definitely on team whitney and
heather and you know what lisa is really
bringing meredith down like because you
know what i actually thought meredith's
apology to i understand exactly where
meredith was coming she doesn't feel
like she started it yeah and like
she shouldn't have said like she this
all happened to her last season and
at first i wasn't understanding if
meredith like wants to explore mary
stuff and i thought jenny was so also
off the mark when she was like you don't
talk about your friends behind their
back but you hired a private
investigator um she stole from her store
wait but i don't think hiring a private
investigator is like talking behind
someone's back like that's just like
fact jenny's like sorry useless um and
she's like kind of spineless and she
just like follows lisa yeah no i was
just like that's your takeaway from here
that like comparing it to her having a
private investigator when like they're
it's just like no it's right and jen
literally was it was the messiest
episode of anything i've ever seen in my
whole life and of course we're getting
off track i mostly stand with meredith
because i think she is the most sensible
in general but um when it comes to all
of this i'm just like who what i have no
allegiances anymore i really felt felt
like we were getting somewhere and now
we're getting nowhere but i agree like
i'm out on mary i'm halfway out on lisa
i'm gonna give her like next episode
just to try and understand yeah um and
halfway out on whitney and heather
really is just
coming off all wrong i know this season
she's just like a little all over the
place like she has no like values like
she's just she's just yeah she just
flips so hard in such extreme ways even
in like the stuff with her sister like
and her previous life like when she was
a mormon and she went so hard for
mormonism and like and cut out
everything she's an extremist
extremist she just goes so hard in the
moment for whatever it is that she's
feeling and the next day it can be
completely different yeah but it's like
take your time relax yeah relax like and
not everything needs to be so extreme no
it was extremely messy but my biggest
takeaway from the episode was like
mary's awful like i can't with her like
it was funny for a while but she's
actually like an awful person no mary's
awful and all i could think about was
like
when she says little girl a little girl
and then so leave little girl miss
hannigan little girl
she's just hannigan
little girl anymore which is
really frustrating
little girl
[Laughter]
um so it was like honestly a really dumb
boring episode because i was like where
is jen like this is so cute but if we
didn't have this fight they would have
been back in by from vail by now
yeah and we're getting so
sidetracked yeah but i have to tell you
that okay so after my show in toronto i
went to simon and phil's wedding so i
went to the wedding in la and they had
another small wedding in toronto simon's
canadian it was just like crazy
coincidence and i got like really really
drunk and then on my way out like
someone was smoking a joint and i was
like okay like i don't really smoke a
lot of pot i was
so high i got home and i started
watching coming out colton
jackie when i tell you i was
sobbing like
i because you know when like all my
inhibitions of like hating colton and
like all the things that like i know
about him my guard was down i was crying
but i did this is what i want to say
only did you watch any of it sober no um
and if oh yeah no i didn't and i watched
like the first two episodes where he
just is like basically coming out to
everyone and i do feel like it's bizarre
that like he's
like having these conversations like
with his parents and a camera crew and a
camera crew yeah like there were certain
people okay like his best friend from
home whatever this girl sure film it but
like your dad
very weird like it's it's giving thirst
monster like it's really bizarre it's
insanely the response i watched the
trailer and i'm not gonna lie it did
look very compelling yeah you know like
you like i hate colton like he
aggressively stalked his ex-girlfriend
put a tracking device on his car um and
i don't think that like coming out is an
excuse for bad behavior because it's
just not but
the stuff that he's gone through as a
person who's struggling with their
sexuality like he did say he did try to
kill himself like it was very it was
moving i'm sorry like it really wasn't i
know everyone hates him it was very it
was moving i can imagine the show is
moving and i think he addresses a lot of
the cassie he tries to go head-on but
like people just are not having no but
no one even wants to give him that
chance and like he shouldn't have this
platform this show on netflix so that
might be everything like you know the
other people get free form and colton's
on netflix and he's like and he's the
one who's committing crimes against like
i understand the outrage i feel like
maybe if people watch the show which i
didn't but i found the trailer to be
very compelling and long so i feel like
i was there yeah that maybe they would
turn a corner on him a little bit but i
don't think anybody wants no one's
giving you a chance no one's giving him
the corner to turn no one's interested
in giving out corners no but i did watch
also love hard
so i watched the whole thing and then i
had 20 minutes left when i got back from
the wedding and that was really high and
i don't really remember how it happens
but spoiler alert
it's not that big of a spoiler
oh my god almost called her victoria
justice they look so much like her nina
jobrev and that guy ended up together
which like what they didn't even have
any romantic connection like he
obviously liked her but she looked
didn't even see him um i thought the
movie was great let me say a few things
they really she
sees him on the dating app at the end
when he's like made his profile yeah
that's when the tear came to my eyes
that was really sweet i forgot about oh
my god i was literally like chills he
was such a cutie and honestly he was too
good for her couldn't agree more for her
so she was so worse she was the worst so
[ __ ] shallow shallow
like when she was just going running
around town like a big dope trying to
make herself cool for paxton hall
yoshida he's from
the guy who plays the cute one tag tag
is from his name is pax and honey shida
in some other tv show um oh okay that's
why i called him i never saw him before
so i thought that was his real name he's
super cute um i was like this girl is
the biggest loser i've ever met in my
life like the the ice losing and the
rock climbing i'm like her character was
like she was physically catfished by
josh and now she's emotionally
catfishing tag like when will this girl
learn and she's also a dating expert no
thanks keep your advice to yourself but
i have a bone to pick with netflix
because they really teased heather in
that [ __ ]
trailer she was hands down the best part
of the movie when she's pouring scotch
into her mug and then her phone she's
like oh honey i gotta go it's my sponsor
she was so good she's like so good and
we got nothing from her like we we
needed more no she needed to fly out of
lake placid yes or even at the end for
the engagement party yes wrap it up i
agree it wasn't enough and in the
trailer like they're showing you the
setup for the movie and so like the best
friend is very much a part of the setup
but then it just wasn't enough heather
considering she was so funny a star like
you know what she was giving me tiffany
haddish in
girls trip where it was like this random
movie that launched her career like
heather was so funny like i just loved
seeing her act i've never seen her act
before me too so the movie was oh and i
guess i
didn't put together that the movie's
called love hard because like love
actually die hard yep stupid um so there
were things about it i liked things that
i didn't like just nina dobrev in
general um
but it was cute i didn't think they
really should have ended up together
though they had no chemistry yeah that's
what olivia said when we watched it but
she thought like someone else was gonna
come out of the
i was like who is the winner here like i
couldn't no i figured you know what she
really needed to work on herself she did
i figured that they would end up
together but i thought he was way too
good for her and that he could do so
much better but you're right when his
profile came up and he had like his
smile and he took his glasses off
i was crying that was so cute and he had
like answer to the questions and he was
just like being himself he was so cute
honestly like he needed to leave this
toxic woman behind him yeah they're not
going to go far as a couple
yeah but it was a it was a good movie
didn't make you think of the idea of
catfishing differently
yes because like there was no reason he
was such a nice guy okay so you trust
this guy enough to stay in his basement
with him but like you're not gonna give
him a chance why because he's not your
traditional like hunk you're shallow no
when it's like you guys had such a good
connection you connected on so many
levels and even like by day two or three
like you guys are laughing at the same
things it's very clear that like you
have this you got over it emotional
connection
why so shallow shallow shallow hell
shallow nina we need a shallow hal like
re remake even though maybe it's just
perfect the way it is so i don't know it
just made me think of like neve and the
whole cappuccino never differently i'm
like yeah why can't you guys just love
each other blind right no that's true
i see that foreign um so yeah that's the
tv recap right anything else that is no
i've just been reading um most of the
weekend and i didn't oh i finished uh i
caught up on dynasty oh wow i'm like i
just needed like in a
moose boosh like some good looks and
it's such a good show to just like fall
asleep too
and this season was crazier than ever
and the way that it ended was just
shocking i'm not going to give away any
spoilers so dynasty it's so dynasty but
it's just like so funny it's like a
gorgeous show to watch
gorgeous show to watch and i just i mean
fallon and liam do stumble upon some
hard times and like i'm over that
they're the backbone of this show and so
that cuts me to the core yeah and i just
feel like they're so perfect for each
other that like this the narrative
doesn't work in a way where like they
don't end up together i hate when they
do that [ __ ] like but they definitely go
through it but
it's okay i think it will turn out fine
okay
um so that is our show
our show ours
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitch or
public radio i have radio catwalks all
the places we've listed podcasts find us
more until seven five star view about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
and if you made it to the end of this
episode i'm sorry we've been forgetting
to do the emojis like all week we've
been so rushed
but i think today we should put the
emoji of the heart on fire in honor of
jackie's heartburn okay how's that
claudia it's beautiful thank you guys we
love you we'll see you tomorrow